[Musique]
bonjour mygale masse bonjour bonjour à
tous les auditeurs tout les auditrices
de la première qui nous écoutent de par
le monde particulièrement ceux et celles
de sept maris oui où vous êtes donc
candidat pour les élections municipales
et communautaires prochaine avec cette
particularité c'est que megan fox vous
avez un emploi donc à la ville de sainte
marie à la municipalité de sainte marie
alors c'est vrai que je suis agent
territorial et j'ai exercé mes fonctions
à la vivre de cette marie jusqu'à
récemment et pour me lancer dans cette
aventure politique jusqu'à récemment
ah oui jusqu'à récemment parce qu'on me
lancer dans cette aventure politique
eh bien j'ai demandé à mettre en stand
by ma carrière ça s'appelle une mise en
disponibilité donc le fonctionnaire
arrête tout lien avec sa collectivité
n'est pas payée pour pouvoir s'exprimer
en tant que libres citoyens devant la
population alors présentez-vous meygal
masse est ce que vous êtes samaritain
l'origine meygal masse presque 45 ans
samaritain pure souche
donc j'ai toujours vécu à sept maris je
suis plus particulièrement logé au bourg
de sept maris et
écoutez je suis plus grands font de
cette marque effectivement alors bon je
connais tout de même l'évolution de
cette mari depuis les 20 dernières
années
je n'ai pas forcément suivi en politique
les responsables qui étaient mais j'ai
tout de même ma vision mon mon
expérience de ce qu'a été ma commune
depuis les vingt voire les trois
dernières années
on va y venir votre âge et votre
profession alors j'aurai bientôt 45 ans
comme j'ai dit et je suis un
informaticien communicants alors
pourquoi avoir décidé de vous présenter
à ces élections
alors vous avez il ya beaucoup
d'histoires relative ce qui peut vous
déclenchez l'envi de vous lancer dans ce
type d'aventuré maintenant en toute
humilité est vraiment sans prétention
aucune je pense qu'avec le groupe qui
m'entourent nous sommes le meilleur
choix
aujourd'hui pour les samaritains ce
scrutin là pourquoi je le dis parce que
nous venons avec un état d'esprit une
volonté d'agir uniquement à sainte marie
pour son mari nous ne sommes pas
intéressés par d'autres prêts et je vais
dire où les absorbent leur est plus
verte donc nous sommes seulement
intéressé par la mairie et nous avons
une connaissance quasi exacte exhaustive
pendant deux des institutions et de leur
fonctionnement
nous connaissons très bien le personnel
municipal que je salue en passant et
donc je crois que ce sont des avantages
des atouts qui font que nous avons déjà
une feuille de route
nous savons déjà pertinemment ce que
nous allons faire si nous sommes en
responsabilité parce qu'aujourd'hui je
ne veux pas je ne vais pas vous cacher
que alors on va où il va on va on va
évoquer bien sûr vos priorités vous
aideront les parties mais juste une
précision le le nom de votre groupe
et s'il est différent le nom de votre
liste alors un seul nom c'est marie en
avant sept maris en avant c'est une
appellation qui n'a pas de sens caché
mais qui veut dire que ça sera d'abord
marie sept maris avant qu avant tout et
aussi scénarii pour aller plus loin don
en avant on ne recule pas nous ses
doigts devant mai
vous êtes personnel parce que souvent
les listes sont composées de deux
personnes à nos sensibilités
idéologiques assez différentes des fois
c'est pas plus mal
mais vous à titre personnel est-ce que
vous avez une sensibilité idéologique
est ce que vous vous situez à sur
l'échiquier politique notamment
martinique d'accord à titre personnel
j'ai un mot qui est le mot le plus
important de mon lexique politique c'est
le mot émancipation le mot émancipation
a d'abord une connotation de changement
donc changer d état d'esprit d'abord
pour aller plus loin dans des
changements pour le pays en lui même
mais non on ne parle pas forcément
d'indépendance ni d'autonomie encore
moins de l'assimilationnisme je crois
que le pape n'ait pas encore
suffisamment mûres dans sa tête pour
pouvoir choisir vraiment la voie qui lui
convient c'est pour ça que
l'émancipation c'est d'abord faire
prendre conscience à tout à chacun de
l'environnement dans lequel il vit dans
le type de société dans lequel il se
trouve à l'est quels sont les
changements qui sont même eu tendance
est donc votre proposition phare pour la
population samaritaine à l'entrée c'est
très sincèrement je pense que pourquoi
pas aucun peuple soit respectée
il doit d'abord pouvant se nourrir par
lui-même
c'est l'une de mes préoccupations
premières arrivées à une certaine
autosuffisance alimentaire
pas seulement sur sept maris mais aussi
sur la martinique vous avez ce sont donc
bien grand mot mais forcément il ya des
agriculteurs derrière qui doivent eux
mais griffe en terre et pour cela je
crois qu'il faut réconcilier l'aspect
économique des choses puisque les gens
ne travaillent pas pour rien l'heure
qu'il est nous sommes en temps de paix
donc mettre en place des structures qui
crient au ccri endogène sur cette marie
très bien merci mygale masse d'avoir
répondu à nos questions dans ce cinq à
dix spéciales municipal c'est moi qui
vous remercie